last thing on what this thing does happy
new year you guys what's happening 2016
ETS I'm so psyched 2015 was an
incredible year for me 2016 I think it's
gonna be even better I'm really looking
forward to it I'm so grateful I woke up
today sober present with good energy
well rested and I'm not hating on anyone
who went out and partied like crazy on
New Year's Eve believe me I've done my
share of that and it was a disaster but
I'm just grateful in my own experience
to not do that anymore and to have a
different experience with New Year's Day
and it really is quite something to wake
up early in the morning when you know
most people are sleeping off a hangover
and really attack the day with vigor and
vitality it's a beautiful thing we've
created this sort of social tradition of
going out and getting absolutely
hammered on New Year's Eve so that we
wake up on the first day of the year the
day of the year that we've put all this
in tension and energy behind cultivating
sort of goals and aspirations for that
year the first day of that year we wake
up and we feel absolutely terrible like
that is ridiculous when you think about
it right so I am really grateful to have
a different relationship with New Year's
Day I'm gonna used to this is the time
of year for resolutions for visioning
for goal-setting and the truth is I
think we all know most resolutions don't
work they don't stick people don't stay
with them you start for a couple weeks
you lose interest the momentum kind of
declines and before you know it you're
back to square one except it's actually
even worse because you're in this like
shame spiral because you've committed to
doing something
and then failed yourself the whole thing
is a giant disaster it's a big mess it
doesn't really work so how can we do
better
what's a different way of approaching
this well I think it's fine to have
goals and to set goals that's super
important goals create structure in your
life and structures very important it is
in my life but I think there's too much
focus on this distant future event we
really need to anchor ourselves in the
present moment and and put our intention
or focus on what we're doing right now
because in truth it's the micro actions
the micro decisions those tiny little
things that you do on a daily basis
throughout your day every single day
that's the key to growth and that is the
key to achieving your dreams and your
goals for 2016 there's plenty of things
that I want to achieve some big goals
one of those things isn't really a goal
though and that is to focus on video
focus on YouTube it's not a goal it's
really a decision this video that you're
watching right now is a reflection of
that decision the podcast has been this
incredible gift and there is no better
medium than podcasting for delivering
mature nuanced long-form conversations
but an incredible journey but it's
two-dimensional and there's just
something undeniably powerful palpable
and riveting about video and it's
something that I really just haven't
explored or developed in the advocacy
work that I do I do a lot of public
speaking and I can't tell you how many
times people come up to me and they say
oh my goodness I've seen all your videos
like what videos now to be sure I have
videos I've had a YouTube channel since
I think like 2009 but it just sits there
I really haven't developed it I haven't
done very much other than dabble in it
and I think that's a testament to how
powerful video is and I think it was
like a lightbulb moment for me helping
me to realize like this is something I
really need to pay attention to and put
some intention behind the goal part of
this for me is that I'm going to be
putting up a minimum of one video per
week every week for 2016 and I'm nervous
I'm like scared about it I'm intimidated
I real
don't know how to use this camera I
really don't know how to edit I'm being
honest with you I really don't know what
I'm doing what is it that you would like
to see me do on this channel that would
be helpful to you because really that's
all this is for me I'm just trying to
find new and better and more dynamic
compelling ways to connect with you guys
the audience and be of service to you so
to the extent that I can do that
by virtue of YouTube through this
platform through this distribution this
means of distribution then that's what I
want to do so please subscribe to the
channel and in the comments section
below let me know what you thought of
this hacky in amateur video and what you
would like to see from me in future
videos that would be interesting or
helpful to you so that's really hate you
guys that's my big pitch for 2016 it's
not about the resolutions it's about
what you're doing right now the more
aware and present you are in the
decisions that you're making and the
thoughts that you're entertaining then I
think you're gonna be in a better
position to make better choices to
really work on eradicating the negative
behavior patterns that are holding you
back and moving forward on a more
healthy better more efficient trajectory
towards achieving your goals that's my
big speech you guys happy new year
Oman USA Happy New Year peace plan
[Music]
I think it's a little overexposed is it
not Oh